conditional probabilities our
probabilities associated with a revised
model that takes into account some
additional information about the outcome
of a probabilistic experiment the
question is how to carry out this
revision of our model we will give a
mathematical definition of conditional
probabilities but first let us motivate
this definition by examining a simple
concrete example consider a probability
model with twelve equally likely
possible outcomes and so each one of
them has probability equal to one over
twelve we will focus on two particular
events event a and B two subsets of the
sample space event a has five elements
so its probability is five over twelve
and event B has six elements so it has
probability six over twelve suppose now
that someone tells you that event B has
occurred but tells you nothing more
about the outcome how should the model
change first those outcomes that are
outside event B are no longer possible
so we can either eliminate them as was
done in this picture or we might keep
them in the picture but assign them zero
probability so that they cannot occur
how about the outcomes inside the event
B so we are told that one of these has
occurred now these six outcomes inside
the event B were equally likely in the
original model and there is no reason to
change the relative probabilities so
they should remain equally likely in the
revised model as well so each one of
them should have now probability one
over six since there are six of them and
this is a revised model the conditional
probability law zero probability two
outcomes outside B and probability one
over six tweaks to our
the outcomes that is inside the event B
let us right now this down
mathematically we will use this notation
to describe the conditional probability
of an event a given that some other
event B is known to have occurred we
read this expression as probability of a
given B so what are these conditional
probabilities in our example so in the
new model where these outcomes are
equally likely
we note that event a can occur in two
different ways
each one of them has probability 1 over
6 so the probability of event a is 2
over 6 which is the same as 1/3
how about event B well B consists of six
possible outcomes each with her ability
1 over 6 so event B in this revised
model should have probability equal to 1
of course this is just saying the
obvious given that we already know that
B has occurred the probability that B
occurs in this new model should be equal
to 1 how about now if the sample space
does not consist of equally likely
outcomes but instead we are given the
probabilities of different pieces of the
sample space as in this example notice
here that the probabilities are
consistent with what was used in the
original example so this part of a that
lies outside B has probability 3 over 12
but in this case I'm not telling you how
that probability is made up I'm not
telling you that it consists of three
equally likely outcomes all I'm telling
you that the collective probability in
this region is 3 over 12 the total
probability of a is again 5 over 12 as
before the total probability of B is 2
plus 4 equals 612 exactly as before so
it's a sort of similar situation as
before how should we
eyes are probabilities and create
construct conditional probabilities once
we are told that event B has occurred
first this relation should remain true
once we are told that B has occurred
then B is certain to occur so it should
have conditional probability equal to
one how about the conditional
probability of a given that B has
occurred well we can reason as follows
in the original model and if we just
look inside event B those outcomes that
make event a to happen had the
collective probability which was 1/3 of
the total probability assigned to B so
out of the overall probability assigned
to B one third of that probability
corresponds to outcomes in which event a
is happening so therefore if I tell you
that B has occurred
I should assign probability equal to one
third that event a is also going to
happen so that even that B happened the
conditional probability of a given B
should be equal to one third by now we
should be satisfied that this approach
is a reasonable way of constructing
conditional probabilities but now let us
translate our reasoning into a formula
so we wish to come up with the formula
that gives us the conditional
probability of an event given another
event the particular formula that
captures our way of thinking has
motivated before is the following out of
the total probability assigned to B
which is this we ask the question which
fraction of that probability is assigned
to outcomes
under which event a also happens so we
are living inside event B but within
that event we look at those outcomes for
which event a also happens so this is
the intersection of a and B and we asked
out of the total probability of B what
fraction of that probability is
allocated to that intersection of a with
B so this formula this definition
captures our intuition of what we did
before to construct conditional
probabilities in our particular example
let us check that the definition in dye
indeed does what it's supposed to do in
this example the probability of the
intersection was 2 over 12 and the total
probability of B was 6 over 12 which
gives us 1/3 which is the answer that we
had gotten intuitively a little earlier
at this point let me also make a comment
that this definition of conditional
probabilities make sense only if we do
not attempt to divide by 0 that is only
if the event B on which were
conditioning has positive probability if
B if an event B has zero probability
then conditional probabilities given B
will be left undefined and one final
comment this is a definition it's not a
theorem what does that mean it means
that there is no question whether this
equality is correct or not it's just a
definition there's no issue of
correctness the earlier argument that we
gave was just a motivation of the
definition we try to figure out what the
definition should be if we want to have
a certain intuitive and meaningful
interpretation of the conditional
probabilities let us now continue with a
simple example